so one thing I want to cover is this
dirty little secret that most everyone
doesn't know about vitamins being in the
area of vitamins you know I'm able have
a chance to talk with manufacturing
companies and I don't know if you
realize this Karen but 90% of all
vitamins made are synthetic
they're not natural so what does that
mean well if something synthetic it mean
it means that it's made artificially
it's made from petroleum Wow how is that
possible I know that's weird you can
make vitamins Dow Chemical Company is
one of the main companies that makes
synthetic vitamins and so they have ways
of synthesizing them or making them from
petroleum and like for example vitamin C
like you you bought some vitamin C
before right now if you look at the
label it doesn't really tell you all
where it comes from but the way they
make vitamin C is from cornstarch in
sulfuric acid I mean that's crazy isn't
it yes so first of all corn starch has
zero vitamin C okay and sulfuric acid
know about it see but if you combine
these together you make something called
ascorbic acid and what's happening over
the years is we've redefined vitamins
like ascorbic acid is only one little
piece of the vitamin C complex it's not
the whole thing and of course people not
knowing that to think of they're getting
the full thing and then they're taking
it but not seeing the results so with
working with people for many many years
I find out the first thing is like oh
you're taking synthetic vitamins you
don't even know it like what so there's
a huge difference it's like saying
artificial flavoring is the same as
natural flavoring it's not well that
reminds me of something um I had a
friend who was taking high doses of
vitamin C and she started to get broken
capillaries in her nose yeah
well that's a perfect example I normally
vitamin C is supposed to prevent
capillary breakage or spider veins or
varicose veins or bleeding gums but if
you take it synthetic you actually
caused that bleeding and that's because
the active ingredient in the vitamin C
complex
is routine or bioflavonoids it's not
ascorbic acid so vitamin C natural has
all these other things that you're not
getting when you take this straight high
potency ascorbic acid and you end up
creating deficiencies and the very thing
you're trying to get rid of so we need a
diagram yes well I've just put a diagram
up right back here you can check it out
between our heads so right there we go
good so this is the vitamin C complex in
nature as you can see in this diagram
the outside of the shell is ascorbic
acid that's like the banana peel yeah
egg shell to the egg or the banana peel
or the orange peel but the inside of the
vitamin C complex you have copper which
is a mineral you have both flavonoids
that's rooted you have vitamin K and you
have vitamin J and all of these inside
complex parts gee-ya vitamin J is the
called the anti pneumonia vitamin yeah
that's pretty cool it actually helps you
increase oxygen especially when you're
going up inclines so if you're deficient
in vitamin J the J factor you'll go up a
flight of stairs and get out of breath
easily so now you're gonna ask me about
the copper - I did ask you about enough
okay good that's a really good question
so I prompt prompt that question pull
that Ivor thank ya copper is a real key
trace mineral to build collagen and
collagen is what protects the
capillaries so when you're a deficient
in copper you have you don't have enough
collagen so you have you know popping
joints loose joints weak ligaments
tendons sagging skin all sorts of issues
and even a loss of collagen in the
arteries can cause leaky arteries and
even leaky gut nosebleeds bleeding gums
but other than that you're gonna be
pretty much okay okay so I have a
question so how is it that they can put
this little portion of vitamin C of the
real vitamin C in a pill and call it
vitamin C well in 1950
if you look at some of the dictionaries
before about 1950 and after they
basically changed the definition of
vitamin C - meaning I don't know who
they is but meaning vitamin C is
ascorbic acid when reality in nature
vitamin C never comes as ascorbic acid
in nature that's just one little tiny
part of the whole deal the whole
compound so they basically change the
definition and alter that simply
probably because most of the drug
companies supply the raw materials for
the synthetic vitamins so it's a big
business okay so all the vitamins see
not all of it and C but a lot most of
the vitamin C in the store is not the
whole vitamin C no it's not so where do
I get vitamin C there's a whole vitamin
C you always want to get vitamin C from
food or food concentrates now that's why
you know that's why for example I don't
sell a multivitamin or vitamin C hey I
was gonna ask you why don't you sell a
multivitamin you beat me to it or
actually beat you to it it's question 4
well because it kind of defeats the
whole purpose of the person eating
healthy even myself back in what with
20s I was driving around trying to find
a vitamin store go on the store buy all
these vitamins remember that I was like
we had a warehouse of nutrition do they
know we still do okay but before we had
a lot more we mainly have all my our
advice we were searching more now we
know it's good but back then we were
searching I had an absence of awareness
I'd be in a vitamin store and like I was
tired I'm like maybe maybe this will
increase my energy maybe I need this
I've never heard about ginkgo biloba
maybe I'll try that and now we kept
buying more vitamins and that didn't
work because I really at the time I
didn't know it but like nothing worked
because my diet was crappy I didn't know
what to eat so trying to get your
vitamins on top of a bad diet you're not
gonna see results and that's why I don't
have a mold
that's why I don't have vitamin C I want
you to consume like real food to get
that the nutrition that we have
fortifies different things it handles
different weaknesses within the body it
helps enhance things that are hard to
get from our diet so that's why I turn
okay so I have another question in there
that I just forgot okay she were talking
[Music]
the jeopardy theme song
I literally completely blanked out on
that well we can talk about memory for
the next topic no oh here here was the
question because um you know hero d3
deficiency or I have this deficiency or
that deficiency I'm just gonna take some
supplements so does taking a supplement
remedy a deficiency just by itself well
yes and no for example it's very
difficult to determine what you're
deficient in because when you do a blood
test for example in your blood and you
measure it might not show up because the
real problem is in your cells it's in
the tissues it's not showing up in the
blood huh your bile do whatever can to
keep normal blood values so that's the
worst pace place to try to detect about
a min efficiency the best place is in
your hair doing a hair analysis but even
then it might not show up until it's a
very deficient so you really have to
understand some of the symptoms that
vitamin C deficiencies can create and
even then that takes a lot of knowledge
knowledge about the body so I think the
more scary no we're not screwed because
I think what we have to do is just start
eating healthy and we're gonna get what
we need if you need vitamin D for
example you're gonna need about 20
minutes in the Sun that'll give you your
whole day of item D but that one of the
challenges is people take vitamin D and
they don't see any changes because
they're not absorbing vitamin D that's a
really big point
so the question is why I know why okay
but go ahead I know this one
okay so why why would someone not absorb
vitamin D because they don't have the K
oh she does know that I watched your
video she does know probably just that
one video okay good good so we don't
want about mine even came vitamin D I
have a another question because people
are taking vitamins maybe they're even
eating the foods but they're not
handling their vitamin deficiency
because the soil is so crappy yeah
that's that don't get me started on that
one I want to get you started on that so
the problem now in farming is they only
put three minerals basically back into
the soil they're not putting all the
trace minerals you have like like
between 50 and 90 different minerals
that you need in the soil even take a
look at people that grow plants I mean
the amount of problems that people have
like farmers that are growing plants
that have brown leaves or yellow leaves
or they're dying or it's too small or
it's not bearing the fruit those are
vitamin deficiencies well what's
happening when we're consuming that
vegetation on the soil is depleted it's
crazy so it's like you can taste it in
those tomatoes they're just like it's
like wax no flavor at all you just bite
it doesn't smell like anything it
doesn't taste like anything when I was
growing up we had a garden in the
backyard and we grew tomatoes everybody
grew tomatoes everyone was like giving
bags of tomatoes oh they were so red and
we would eat them like apples we would
just take a bite put a little salt on it
and they were so delicious and I can't
even consider doing that with a
store-bought even even inorganic one
well even when we went into your fret
your old house that you grew up in your
friend down the street right around the
block her father we stopped there and
they had this mystery anise uncredible
tomatoes those are the best tomatoes
that have ever I think I still think
about those Tomatoes there was my
cutting again
they're so good so you go to the store
it's like empty nutrition but you saw
what he had he had
compost they saved everything they they
make their compost they nurture the soil
and you know no chemicals there's
nothing better than a good tomato a
healthy tomato there is nothing better
in life is a good mojito Tomatoes just
perfectly oh my gosh again little basil
a couple things a couple things
pecan pie not sugar yeah the soils are
bad okay so that's one thing right and
even if the soil that the farmers
growing the food on is not close to the
ocean you're not gonna get iodine so
you're eating empty nutrition and you're
gonna feel it's like just it's not going
to be satisfying now people in Europe
Russia in different places they come to
America and they get fat eating very
similar foods it's simply because the
soils are empty I mean even though I've
talked to this guys from Russia and he
came here he just bloated out and then
he when he goes home he'll eat the same
calories you eat his food and he's like
a so much richer it satisfies him he's
not hungry as much so I really want to
travel
I've never really too much been out of
country I want to travel to check
different places out for myself or we
want to do that but the point is that
alone I'll be going by myself with a
video now he's going alone oh yeah I'm
going alone
but yeah so it's the soil but there's
some other things can there's other
things that are preventing the nutrients
going in even if you take the nutrients
enzymes how did you know that I got
another one rice you've got another one
right yeah so you cook the food too much
cook food destroys the enzyme now what
does that do that means that now you're
eating foods that are kind of dead so
now your body has to make the own
enzymes to break that food down and also
a lot of the vitamins are heat sensitive
like vitamin C so when you're doing
canned foods canned like what does some
canned like canned beans beans or oh
yeah there's not gonna what about
pasteurized orange
juice hardly anybody Mencia in there if
at all unless they put it there
synthetically so when you pasteurize
food you cook it you roast it you heat
it it's dead I'm sorry well when you put
it that way yeah
it sounds really bad it's really bad
that's why we need a cow we do need a
cow seriously to get some you know so we
can milk the cow or actually when I say
we I mean me huh in the morning make the
cheese in the butter huh
when yeah yeah but here's the thing in
your stomach if you don't have enough
acid in your stomach like a lot of
people have indigestion acid reflux as
they get older they lose the stomach
acid if you don't have that asset you
can't absorb minerals
you can't digest protein so that's
another way you could become deficient
so very common so let's say an the
elderly they have anemia because they
can't pull an iron because their stomach
is too alkaline so that's one thing so
we're so where do you get acid well you
get it your body makes it but if you
think about this the acid your stomach
gets hydrochloric okay hydrochloric the
chloride in hydrochloric comes from
sodium chloride like in salt so people
are low salt diet normally have low
stomach acids so you need the chlorides
from the food from from salt but I
thought salt I that salt wasn't good for
you mmm especially table salt when you
hear that they okay then we know it must
be true
table salt is bad but sea salt is really
good if you're on the keto in the
intermittent fasting program you need a
teaspoon of salt every single day and by
the way day yeah
by the way Karen those cauliflower the
cauliflower that you made yesterday
cauliflower mashed potatoes had
cauliflower mash a lot of salt but no I
loved it it was great because sometimes
it's kind of bland that that was really
enough salt for me yeah that's really
good but the point is you need how to
chloric acid but there's one more thing
and this is like very very important one
is that insulin resistance
it's the pre-diabetic situation that
itself is blocking the absorption of
nutrients potassium protein that's why I
diabetic they start your muscles start
becoming flabby and they become weak and
as you clear that up with the keto in a
minute fasting you start absorbing more
nutrients potassium you get rid of fluid
retention I mean that alone just by
fixing that one problem just by not even
taking nutrition you'll get more
nutrition from the food that you are
eating amazing that's right so it all
comes back it all comes back full circle
to getting the basics then getting your
diet corrected not going out trying to
find a vitamin to correct the symptom
and I think that leads me to the next
topic which is the problem with people
using vitamins to fix symptoms they're
not looking at the cause of the symptoms
so they don't evaluate to know what's
underneath them you know that's your job
that's right
that's why we pay you the big bucks
that's why I have a lot of videos for
free Karen for free on nutrition and how
to fix pretty much almost every thing on
your body so when we get a lot of
questions on Facebook and YouTube a lot
of these questions are already in a
video that you may have not have found
so if you just search for that topic
slash my name you're gonna find answers
to everything's like everything
Hashimoto's that was a question today a
lot of questions on that a leg cramps
yep just pretty much everything skin
skin issues gallbladder little red dots
on your skin missing the gallbladder big
one and that's you know what we should
probably talk about that okay yeah
because we done with vitamins
well that relates to vitamins oh now
Carolyn the gallbladder right do you
know what the Valle butter does it
produces bile and stores bile
okay so you got half of a right it's
stores by good what makes the bile the
liver very good
okay question two now what is bowel do
bile breaks down fat Wow she's smart oh
you sound so surprised well she's really
smart
so bile helps you extract and pull the
nutrients the fat vitamins fat soluble
vitamins are called like vitamin A D E
and K okay it puts us out of the food so
that's what it does so without enough
bile you're gonna be deficient in
vitamin A D and K good girl now that
might not be significant to you unless
you know what that means with your body
so you're gonna get night blindness okay
number one you're gonna have really
scaly dry skin you're gonna have bone
loss okay you're gonna have bone pain
you're gonna have a lot of hormone
issues you're gonna have calcium buildup
in the arteries from the vitamin k2
deficiencies and you'll have bruising
okay but you'll be fine I didn't know
now what about people who don't have a
cobbler and they're good to go right
because it was an extra organ no so
here's a situation you don't have a gall
bladder so that means you can't store
the bile anymore that means you can't
concentrate the bile anymore by 20 times
normally that you need so you can
actually really digest so now you're
gonna have like weak bile and not enough
of it so now we have this tube from your
liver that goes right to the small
intestines and it just trickles down all
day long not when you eat but constantly
so you're gonna be deficient in bile now
you're not gonna probably notice that
right away it's gonna take some years to
develop these deficiencies so in that
case you're gonna have to enhance the
diet with some some bile guys some bile
salts purify bile salts and that's what
you're going to need at least some on a
regular basis to make sure you have
enough to pull that out of the fats that
you eat
or you get by also so you can get it
online there's a product that we have
called gall bladder formula as well it
has a bunch of other things in there in
addition to the bile salts as well
fascinating isn't it well yeah yeah so
now the next question I wanted to ask
you Karen so what was the first vitamin
ever discovered I know this
what a Wow that's pretty good with the
second one B and the third one how long
have we been married
C this is amazing
I know I've done probably like 49
hundred different seminars in a row and
I always ask that question no one has
ever got that right
so well don't care yes thank you I was
at you were at one of the first seven or
700 of them so you were at one of the
seminars at least one of them that's
right mm-hmm yeah so uh let's see what
else do people not know they often ask
it out by to me oh well I mean basically
you deal with vitamins you should deal
with vitamins the same as you deal with
food right you want to eat real food
live food whole complete food not
nothing processed a stripped down cooked
or man-made right unless you know like
when I make pecan pie I'm not looking
for a vitamin source right so that's
different but if you're talking about
food vitamins would be the same they
should be whole and real and life right
and I think that if you're trying to get
a certain nutrient for food it might be
helpful to understand what foods provide
those nutrients or at least a lot of
them sounds like a really long video I'm
gonna make it really little short and
I'm gonna summarize can it be in a song
like the alphabet so that we can
remember it I'll let you put that
together and we'll do that in the next
updated version how about that okay
okay good so
here's the thing when you're trying to
get nutrients from the diet
there's foods that you eat that are very
very low on the list and foods that you
can eat that are very high on the list
so let me just ask you
okay let's pretend that you're an
average processed anxiety right now okay
I need a vitamin I have weird test
anxiety pick one of these call me in the
morning okay
hey Karen I have a quiz for you okay
okay now out of all the category of
foods what category will give you the
most vitamins of anything category now I
need to understand the question you mean
like is it a meat or is it yeah but true
or is it a vegetable that's right okay
well I think vegetable is the comp the
obvious answer that everybody say I
didn't say it I said it would be the
obvious answer and you're testing me Oh
coach means coz you're setting me up
right house for the gong so I'm gonna
say fats ah
meats wait though what else is there
okay good so let me just tell you what
it is okay so you would think I've never
heard of so you get the away galaga Luke
along no no you know about this so you
have vegetables right and then you have
you have iceberg lettuce which is not
very hard right that's an edge to right
so that would be in the loan scale and
then what would be high on the scale of
vegetables yeah kale yeah right and then
you also have sprouts
yes sprouts are a little higher that's a
vegetable mm-hmm but there's something
higher organ meats organ meats organ
meats who would ever think now honestly
I don't like what do you reason why I
didn't think of that I know I don't I
don't really eat a lot of organ meats I
wish I liked them more but I just can't
well yeah yeah but not I don't really
like liver I don't like the taste of it
but it's so good for you if they have a
grass-fed nah I'm not talking about
getting some process you know type organ
meats now I'm not talking about that but
the point is that
you look what are you talking about I'm
talking about that organ meats are rich
in all the fat size of item ins iron
which is a horrible vitamin A which goes
in like a rocket ship
compared to vegetables it's a pre
vitamin A it's like a prior so you're
not you're gonna now the problem is that
excited I was excited about this so
excited about the question where could
you find these organ meats our freezer
right because we get them from a farm a
farm right well we do but I don't know
like a pitch but we do crowd cow take a
cow or it's like co-op I guess kind of
thing yeah but they're all mostly all
really great farms and no preservatives
and grass-fed and things like that and
then you can buy the organ meats from
there and we we have that in our freezer
we have some very delicious liverwurst
okay now I'm gonna put a link down below
of where we got this it's from an online
grass-fed type farm Camden doesn't
really enjoy it as much as the original
liverwurst I was really loving in
Pennsylvania oh and you know you go down
to the local um can I was gonna say cafe
but the diner right and you get a
liverwurst sandwich and it's like a
chunk like this of liverwurst on rye
with yellow mustard and a big ol slab of
onion great for your breath and it's
horrible for your breath
but the liverwurst is so creamy and I
don't know that combination I just
really like I really like it
but then he brought home this a primo
liverwurst and I knew I knew it was
gonna be a different experience the
minute he said that it's a little more
fibrous now I can't I can't think of one
thing where you add that edge
and you go like oh right it's not as
clean not smell like a potato patato
mission of liver in heart yeah and it
might have some kidney in there so
anyway yes it sounds disgusting but it's
all breastfed and my dad would like it
if he was around it's just really really
healthy it was really healthy that's why
I was eating it it wasn't bad
it wasn't terrible yeah so if you like
liver you're gonna like this typically
on average an average person would like
this but I mean if you like it creamy
you know okay we're done talking about
living out I have something else to say
okay go ahead okay you've mentioned
several times today iron and then when
we were doing the other show a lot of
people are asking about the seek help
and keto and so what do they have what
do they have to do with each other and
what does it have to do with your body
why is iron a big deal and and how do
you get it unfortunately all the
vegetables that you eat half iron in it
but it's it's unfortunate unfortunately
has a type of iron that is not in the
active form that that's in red meat and
impress
so you're getting this kind of this like
you can just look at it like a pre
vitamin A iron so it's different I'm not
going to get into the technical part but
if you have an iron deficiency and
you're anemic and you consume like rare
steak or liver or liver worse you're
gonna get a way better source of
available iron to your body than you
would get from eating spinach and that's
the point especially if you're anemic if
you're a vegetarian and you can't do
that there's a big problem because
you're not gonna find that special
activated by iron that is in red meat
and the more rare it is the more
available is so but now you touched on
something is a hot hot hot subject right
was this eating meat and the whole thing
yeah very hot subject so people have
said
they get all the nutrients they need in
beans yeah let's talk about that okay
yeah well I always like to ask him you
get your vitamin A from beans well it
has to be activated you're not getting
retinol there's you're getting a pre
vitamin A that's to be converted in the
body so if you're living on vegetable
sources for your vitamins then you're
only getting maybe three to four percent
if you're lucky of that vitamin A same
thing with the iron you're not getting
the full scoop and also but vitamin b12
now I will say this if you're doing
certain type like even the wheatgrass
juice has a lot of b12 you can do also
spirulina or chlorella these are like
blue green algae type products what's
interesting is that there is no b12 in
that vegetation at all
it's the microbes that are living around
that algae yeah it's the waste products
on microbes that are making to b12 I
don't have a t-shirt like that okay you
do that
I love microbe poop or something I think
you'll sell out it was if you want to
sell them oh you sort of wear it no I
just think it's a funny concept it is a
funny concept but getting back on topic
here getting back on track oh it's not
supposed to mean the microbes that live
this explains that the next concept of
sterilization like having your food so
sterilized and cooked and pasteurized
versus like really good like the
wheatgrass juice how do we have it's raw
it's hardly heat at all
there's friendly microbes living around
that it's very beneficial that's what's
giving you the b12 that's very exciting
so that's one nutrient that a vegan
could get easily but vitamin A is
difficult iron is difficult so they may
need to enhance their diet and where do
you get the iron if you're vegan or not
okay if you're not you're gonna get a
ton from liver liverwurst right don't do
that I'm delete do steak beef and then
what about a vegetarian
well you're gonna have to find a good
natural source and some and supplement
because you're not going to be able to
get it from the food and then what about
seek help does that give seek help is
really really good it's like a vegetable
that lives in the water it has all the
trace minerals that you really need and
it has minerals and it has protein I
mean it's really wonderful but it's may
only gonna be a good thing for your
trace minerals and does that have hired
a little bit but it's not in the active
form that you need to build blood okay
mm-hmm are you doing it has tons of
iodine that you need to help your
thyroid and also to regulate estrogen
but you can get too much iodine you can
get if you take too much of course
you're gonna get too too much iodine but
if you take it in seek out small amounts
you're gonna get enough and you're not
gonna have to worry about it unless you
already have a condition called
hyperthyroidism big word we're not
talking we're not gonna go down they're
not gonna go down but on that note Karen
yeah I think we're gonna end up because
we gave a lot of information and I don't
want to give people information overload
that is good that you aren't going to
that you picked up on that one okay good
well then that's your dose that's right
it's daily your weekly dose that's right
the daily dose of dr. Berg oh that's a
that could be the name of this alright
guys I am invisible all right have a
good one
we'll see you next time